on est tout va par contre
les exportations d'hydrogène vert selon
aussi les capacités qu'on a en
électricité parce qu'actuellement mais
on prévoit que des prochaines années il
va nous manquer d'électricité donc faut
être prudent est-ce que la province va
vraiment épuiser c'est surtout
énergétique au cours des prochaines
années
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai
selon les prévisions d'Hydro-Québec les
besoins en électricité sur le marché
québécois vont passer de 193 TER cette
année après de 205 en 2029 les surplus
qui sont actuellement de Cinq Terres
vont donc baisser graduellement à
compter de 2027 il faudra de l'énergie
supplémentaire d'ici 2029 c'est près de
7 terawatt-heure dont on aura besoin
vous vous demandez sûrement pourquoi les
surplus sont appelés à disparaître
c'est parce que la demande en
électricité va grimper il y a bien sûr
une progression naturelle avec la
population qui augmente l'économie qui
croit mais certains secteurs en
expansion comme les centres de données
et les production d'hydrogène vert et de
biocarburant sont très énergivores c'est
sans oublier la conversion de bâtiments
au chauffage électrique et
l'électrification des transports selon
Hydro-Québec un million de véhicules
électriques vont circuler sur des routes
de la province d'ici 7 ans pour répondre
à la demande la société d'État lancée
des appels d'offres pour obtenir de
nouveaux approvisionnements en énergie
renouvelable
les achats d'électricité ponctuelle sur
les marchés extérieurs vont aussi
augmenter mais il faut garder une chose
en tête Hydro-Québec réserve une partie
de son électricité à l'exportation parce
que c'est rentable l'an passé la société
des temps envoyés 35 terawattheure à nos
voisins nord-américains